uh if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you'd like them to watch and
why
right now bruised
and mainly because it's i directed it
start in it like it's so much of who i
am if you really want to get an idea of
who i am as
the totality of who i am as an artist
from behind the camera to in front of
the camera it would be that um what do
you think it is getting into why i get
to talk to you what do you think it is
about
end of the world movies and tv shows
that people just keep coming back to
them you know what is it about the genre
that people love
i think it scares the crap out of
everybody you know
uh i think we love to watch um
and and sort of uh fantasize about what
could happen you know and then we like
to see and what would we do as human
beings if the worst possible thing did
happen you know it's somehow comforting
to know that
while
that seems terrible it makes our reality
not seem quite as bad as it is also when
you face these big disastrous situations
that could happen but that ultimately
don't happen and people just love a good
ride especially a roland emerick ride
it's a big flashy splashy movie
um and people love to sit and you know
escape you know their own reality in a
big way like this i think too yeah i
watched it yesterday and was very much
uh it was exactly what i needed it was
just pure spectacle and a lot of fun um
and he's also just very good at
destroying the planet um what do you
think
what is what do you think would surprise
people to learn about making a role in
emeric movie like what's it like on set
you know and working with him you know
it's a lot more simple than the the uh
final product like you said you just
love watching this big spectacle
you know the sets aren't as aren't very
big at all a lot of it is green screen
and blue screen that's added later
um he's very
you know
not he's not very stressed out about
anything
you know he just has a knowing and he
has a confidence and you know what he's
doing and it's a lot smaller
and more contained than you might think
from watching the final product
what what do you think what ended up
being the more challenging stuff to film
in this versus maybe what you expected
going in
i think it was probably uh sitting in
that cockpit with the guys
and really trying to imagine
you know what we would see you know what
does it really look like you know to fly
into
the middle of the moon you know like i
knew we wouldn't see a beach with
seashells on it you know so what would
we see
you know
um and so we all had i think different
versions or different ideas about what
would be inside there and so
you know that was it for me
the thing about this movie is it the
third act is all obviously vfx and if it
doesn't look good this movie does not
work thankfully it looks good um so
exactly so what was it like for you
watching the the film for the first time
and seeing what roland had actually put
on screen because those vfx looked real
good in the third act really and it was
amazing because like i said as actors we
saw none of that we really just saw a
blue and green screen and we had his
interpretation of what it would be we
saw some pre-visits to give us an idea
but for the most part you know i sat
there and i watch it as a as a fan as a
movie goer and i'm just like wow i had
no idea would be that big or wow i
didn't know it looked that good or whoa
that's what we were flying through you
know so i love
you know when i got to see that even
though i made the movie there was still
so much for me to learn and see that i
had no idea i was going to see
yeah i mean
especially when it's again vfx heavy and
you've done these before but um i know
that you're also doing netflix's the
mothership which is another sci-fi type
thing um what can you tease about that
well that you know again that's going to
be another uh
visual effects movie not as heavy as
this by any means but you know it's
pretty impressive to find a spaceship
buried in your backyard you know and
what that would look like and what that
would mean for you as a family you know
if you found such a thing so it's i'm
excited for that one too
uh i was a fan of your directing as i
mentioned at the beginning with bruised
and when i spoke to you for that a while
ago um you mentioned uh that you were
thinking about directing again
have you
been pursuing any script are you getting
behind the camera again soon
i am going to get behind the camera
again i don't really have you know i
can't tell you what i'm doing for sure
for sure yet but i definitely want to do
it again and i definitely will not act
in it this time
directing is is largely enough well i
think
i i would imagine that maybe getting the
financing for bruised also helped with
you being on camera as well or am i
wrong about that
i don't really think so that that was a
tough way to go you know there's a whole
story i could tell you about that that i
won't but
finding that financing uh was really
tough one day we had money one day we
didn't even once we started to shoot i
was told countless times that we were
going to be shut down because the money
just wasn't coming through the way it
was promised so
you know but you do things like that
because they're labors of love and i had
to tell that story so i had to keep
pushing through but it was
it was really challenging on many many
levels
i'm very happy you made it thank you so
much for talking with me today and i
wish you nothing but the best in the
future thank you thank you so very much
you